heute ist der beginn der sommerzeit und
seit dem 20 märz sind wir offiziell im
frühling wie kriechen aus unseren
löchern die sonne scheint endlich mal
wieder und im sonnenlicht kommt der
staub zum vorschein denen wir die
letzten fünf monate gekonnt übersehen
haben das kann nur eins heißen es ist
zeit für den frühjahrsputz
vale und wenn nämlich noch nicht
abonniert habt dann tut das doch jetzt
gerne und gibt dem video einen daumen
nach oben das pusht nicht nur mich
sondern auch meinen kanaldeckel als ich
meine wohnung in einem blog des video
geputzt hat seit ihr fast ausgerastet
vorfreude also gibt es hier eine neue
ladung aber
was steht denn dieses mal auf unserem
kurs plan die fenster müssen unbedingt
geputzt werden auch die staubecken an
die man nie denkt der kühlschrank
bekommt ein makeover und mein
kleiderschrank braucht unbedingt eine
neue ordnung marienbad und abstellkammer
aber dass sehr wohl klar aber das
wichtigste mein bett bekommt ein
komplett neues set und da kommen wir
auch schon zum sponsor dieses videos
immer matratze auf der website findet
ihr tolle angebote und darüber hinaus
spart ihr mit dem code x wanne 5% und ob
dieser code ist für sechs monate in
deutschland österreich und der schweiz
gültig war emma findest du die ma wan
federkernmatratze mit einer verbesserten
atmungsaktivität und memory schaum für
optimale druckentlastung und so wie es
sich für den frühjahrsputz gehört ist
der bezug natürlich waschbar neben der
matratze gibt es aber auch betten
lattenroste topper decken und kissen
aber nicht nur normale kissen sondern
dass emma original kissen aber dazu
später mehr aus aktuellem anlass möchte
ich noch erwähnen dass mein altes bett
zu behörden nicht auf dem müll landet
ich werde alles bei 60 grad waschen was
ich nicht für meine gäste behalten
möchte das wird natürlich an
hilfsorganisationen gespendet und jetzt
lasst uns loslegen
wir fahren natürlich in meinem
schlafzimmer an hier gibt es unter
anderem
einen kleiderschrank ja wieder
katastrophal aus italien klamotten ich
habe es schon ein gefühl 100 videos
gesagt aber ich wechseln immer zur
sommer- und winterzeit meine klamotten
denn die nehmen einfach viel platz raus
und ich brauche im frühling und sommer
keine police also keine strickpullis und
ich habe mir endlich bessere
aufbewahrungsfristen gekauft bei meinl
waren immer viel zu groß und ich habe
sie nie vom kleiderschrank runter
bekommen da musste ich im kino frage
also let's go macht man
da
hallo das ist lieb ich aber es ist nach
dem ersten waschen guck mal wie das kann
man noch nie anziehen
[Musik]
das ist hat einen ganz bestimmten look
haben möchte noch einholen aber auf dem
steht marion drauf der politik muss
bleiben
würdest du dir hier deswegen bin ich
hier
so wird gesucht diesen kisten von der
klamotten wir haben jetzt alle klamotten
sortiert das ist der haufen von
klamotten wo ich sage lieber das mit
jetzt einsortiert wie sound track von in
kanto in
kanto in münchen den bayerischen
pictures darum schwenk von den wänden
berlin franco und konsum cars
[Musik]
bei dem staub müssen die harten
geschütze rausgefahren
[Applaus]
der kleiderschrank hat mich schon echt
überfordert weil ich gar nicht wusste
dass ich so viele klamotten habe ich
denke es sammelt sich einfach viel über
die jahre an und da ist es schön wenn
man es spenden kann an freunde oder
verwandte oder an hilfsorganisationen
oder man verkauft es auf einem flohmarkt
dann macht man sogar noch einen cent
dazu aber jetzt erstmal zum vorher und
nachher
[Musik]
wir kommen zum star des tages mein bett
ja das kann man zu meinem bett sagen wir
haben uns dieses wunderschöne welt zum
einzug in diese wohnung gekauft und die
decken und kissen sind noch von vor
meiner kindheit hier an das bett jetzt
einmal frei und dann kommen wir schon
zum sponsor dieses videos denn dieses
video ist gesponsert und jetzt alle
dieses video ist gesperrt
[Musik]
die flächen zeigen wir euch jetzt nicht
don luis liebherr wie
wir haben hier den wind barend opfer von
emma den papi jetzt mal aus
aber hier wird noch tolerabel sein
kissen man bekommt eigentlich
also ihr fragt euch zu recht vanessa was
hast du denn hier in der hand es ist
dass emma kissen das ist nicht irgendein
kissen sein mag ist
diese küssen so gewünscht
ja das ist zieht sich auf jeden fall
draußen leute ist das ist manchmal mache
ich diesen job zu denken ja und die hält
kommentare ich schlafe ich werde das ist
wie es ist wenn man auf dem normalen
kissen wenn man ja auch hören
rudi emma
flippt oper hat eine ganz bequeme
besonderheit um ein optimales
liegegefühl zu erzielen hat dieser
truppe eine feste und eine weiche seite
und lässt sich super easy wenden auch
hier kann man den atmungsaktiven bezug
abnehmen und waschen mit dem emma
original kissen können fast alle ihre
schlaf bedürfnisse optimal anpassen
dieses kissen hat verschiedene schichten
die individuell entnommen werden können
so dass man seine optimale schlaf höhe
einstellen kann und nicht mehr zu hoch
oder zu niedrig schleef ideal also für
alle rücken seiten und bauch schläfer
wenn du dich für eine emma one matratze
entscheidest hast du nicht nur zehn
jahre garantie auf den federkern sondern
kannst diese auch 100 nächte lang
probeschlafen dabei sind der versand und
abholung inklusive also schaut mal
vorbei und spart mit meinem code x wanne
5% alle infos in der infobox das bett
ist jetzt neu ausgestattet beim
frühjahrsputz geht es ja auch ein
bisschen darum machen um zu gestalten
die man vielleicht nicht mehr mag so wie
sie sind wie zum beispiel dieses
wandfarbe ich mag sie nicht mehr ich
weiß nicht warum ich sie damals
ausgewählt habe ich fand sie ganz cool
aber unseren altrosa flieder lila ich
kann diese farbe nicht beschreiben
angesagt schwein ich sag raus damit und
ich habe noch ein bisschen rest farbe
aus meinem arbeitszimmer und heißen topf
die sieht auch nicht wirklich anders aus
die farbe aber so ein bisschen und dann
dachte ich ja warum nicht halt noch mal
darauf streichen und wir wechseln die
gardinen weil die sind ganz schön
abdunkeln wenn man zum beispiel am tag
sich umziehen möchte weil die nachbarn
da sind muss man sie halt zu ziehen dann
ist es ja so stoppt ostern ich hätte
gerne guardian dies nicht so dunkel
machen ja morgens ist es dann dadurch
heller als wenn man in seiner
dunkelkammer liegt aber jetzt machen mit
[Musik]
mir ist da kann man mal endlich auf den
tisch
[Musik]
haben wir zur lustigsten sachen er war
am meisten spaß macht abgeben würde mich
schon so als klein ab klebt profi
bezeichnet
[Musik]
sonst wird abgeklebt und jetzt wird
gestrichen
ok
[Musik]
aber das ist mal gesehen hat man hier
sowieso
also das geil
es ist ein fitness workout hier
[Musik]
ähnliches war wirklich ein feuer aus
die wand gestrichen
watching payne 3 der wand farbe beim
trocknen zu sehen ist ein englisches
sprichwort dass langeweile ausdrücken
soll aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz
schön
[Musik]
draußen schreit ein kind wir machen
jetzt
[Musik]
wo als eine kleine kannte sie ist dass
tine wittler wieder mal gemeinsam
[Musik]
anni was wäre wenn wir anstatt
den top beide top drauf packen
es ist echt doch
dann muss ich die nicht wegschauen wir
machen jetzt mal beide tore wieder drauf
timo sagt er sieht nicht wirklich einen
unterschied zwischen den zwei wandfarben
ich weiß was er meint aber ich finde
schon dass dieser ton viel erdiger und
ruhiger ist und die luftig leichten
gardinen machen gleich lust auf den
frühling na ja und dann haben wir noch
alles aufgeräumt und hier ist das vorher
nachher
[Musik]
die räume jetzt die couch bereich aus
wie anders fiel hier zu tun
[Musik]
meinen hintern in die kamera zwei kannst
nur eins heißen ganz schön schlimm aus
erwartet ist niemanden aber so sieht es
in meiner haut mein gott ich glaube ich
habe drei jahre nicht gesagt
[Musik]
aber ich habe ja natürlich noch ein aus
ab
[Musik]
da wollen wir doch mal sehen
es ist wirklich schon peinlich wie
dreckig meine fenster vorher waren aber
wer hat bitte schön zeit fürs
fensterputzen okay danach sehen sie
natürlich
fantastisch aus und vielleicht sollte
man es doch öfter machen der kühlschrank
sie vielleicht nicht ganz so aus wir
noch vor zwei jahren aussah aber
es mangelt uns nicht das ist auch meine
sache ich
diva spenden los
[Musik]
relativiert wird
hmm ja
jetzt kommt halt der spaßige teil
[Musik]
das
lernen
[Musik]
diesen monat getroffen
nein
[Musik]
die eine seite haben jetzt hab ich
geschossen
und sind jetzt kommt der beste teil des
eingeräumt an die auch kühlschrank
putzen das wirklich die anstrengendste
aufgabe die es gibt oder ich finde es so
krass macht ein richtig fertig wegen
sieht auch bei den meisten leuten der
küche einfach nicht sauber wir waren
einkaufen und haben ganz fantastische
produkte wieder für den innenbereich
gekauft weil wenn man schon mal den
kühlschrank für den frühjahrsputz macht
dann extra extra extra für sagen die
kohle des der abteilung sind hier für
meine hamburger mäuse habe ich natürlich
auch was gekauft hätte ich hab ich nicht
nur alkohol gekauft jeden fall braucht
ein gut show im vorstand ist das sind
annes lieblings schokoriegel aus polen
bisschen reggae summer geile frikadellen
darf auch nicht fehlen sponsort also
jetzt ist ihr allerdings muss auch seien
sie roger roger mario
herrlich salatdressings sehr wichtig und
jetzt kommen die immer schon
[Musik]
harris-moore das ist meine hast seite
ich hasse den ins gefrierfach ich habe
das über letzten zwei jahre so
vollgestopft ich glaube nicht bei
unserem kühlschrank aufräumen video
haben wir die seite aufgeräumt
[Musik]
draußen das war folgenden video im
browser eis
[Musik]
eingefroren sind ja alle geplatzt
support package
[Musik]
eröffnungs moment meine damen und herren
ich präsentiere euch meinen kühlschrank
[Musik]
den kühlschrank aus zu lernen fällt mir
so unglaublich schwer weil ich mich
nicht von irgendwelchen saucen trennen
möchte aber wie jan böhmermann letztens
schon bei festen flauschig gesagt hat da
sammelt sich einfach über jahre
irgendwas an was man gar nicht mehr
braucht und das muss dann auch wirklich
mal gehen ich finde aber dass vorher
nachher lässt sich diesmal wirklich
sehen
[Musik]
machen wir beide mit dem nächsten raum
ich nenne ihn die kammer des schreckens
ihr könnt euch denken warum oder ja komm
jeder hat diesen raum oder klar wieder
war schwer sich alles raus
ein fensterrahmen
[Musik]
auch eine kurze fahrt
hast du jemals genutzt einmal
da kommt es ist der tag ich versteigert
dieses bild der meistbietende bekommt es
danke für diese abgeschottet
tieflader
[Musik]
und hier ist jetzt platz für unsere
abstellkammer
schluss am vortag
und jetzt ist er die abstellkammer auch
schon fertig so einfach war das
gedacht ich nicht
[Musik]
ja mein badezimmer ist tatsächlich nicht
ganz so viel auszuräumen wie ich dachte
denn ich habe das vor ein paar monaten
schon mal gemacht also das ganze alte
make-up weg geräumt aber
als der alltag muss auch aufgeräumt
werden und weil es so schön aussieht
machen wir jetzt
[Musik]
das major unterschätzt
vor allem hat jeder lippenstift einfach
dieselbe farbe einmal einmal die farbe
okay
[Musik]
also kann sich auf jeden fall drei
millionen mascara mitnehmen
und glaube
[Musik]
jetzt packe ich dann nur noch rein was
ich täglich benutzt make up ist schon so
eine sache für sich ich finde man hat so
viele produkte die man eigentlich nicht
wirklich braucht aber nur weil ich ein
lippenstift zweimal benutzt habe und ihn
danach nicht mehr so schön finde kann
ich ihnen noch nicht einfach
wegschmeißen nein das sollte man auch
nicht machen also wenn man sein make-up
aussortiert sollte man erst mal schauen
wie lange ist es noch haltbar man sollte
wirklich ein bisschen mehr darauf achten
dass man produkte nicht irgendwie zwei
jahre nach dem mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
oder nach diesem deckelchen wurden zwölf
monate drauf steht irgendwie noch weiter
verwendet was noch gut ist und was man
nicht mehr braucht kann man immer weiter
verschenken da freut sich sicher
irgendwer aus eurem freundeskreis von
eurer familie oder in irgend einer
facebook-gruppe jemand darüber und gut
beim lippenstift das ist jetzt
vielleicht bisschen schwieriger aber ihr
wisst was ich meine trennt euch von
sachen die ihr nicht benutzt weil sie
machen nicht nur eure schränke voll
sondern auch euren kopf
[Musik]
ja und so kurz mal seine wohnung an
einem tag leute nehmt euch ein gutes
beispiel an mir ich bin perfekt nein
natürlich haben wir sechs tage gebraucht
wir dachten wir brauchen zwei tage am
zweiten tag haben wir dann gemerkt das
wird noch eine längere geschichte aber
wir haben es geschafft macht euch keinen
druck wenn ihr sowas sieht das ist mein
beruf und ich konnte zum glück mein
beruf und meine pflichten zusammensetzen
ich habe das ja schon auf instagram
gepostet und da hat jemand gesagt dass
er mit kinder alles zu drei vier wochen
dafür plant seinen frühjahrsputz zu
machen andere machen ihn auch gar nicht
das ist ja auch alles wie ihr das machen
wollen aber ich habe keine verantwortung
no strings attached tun also keine
kinder kein keine tiere renault team und
wir müssen nur auf uns selber aufpassen
deswegen mit respekt an alle eltern da
draußen dies schaffen neben ihren
kindern noch irgendwie ein haushalt zu
schmeißen der nicht absolut untergeht
ich bin super happy und das und ich
liebe die neue gardine ich mag es ein
bisschen mehr lichtern zu haben morgens
ein bisschen blöd sein da hat man
natürlich dann schon die morgendliche
stimmung passt vielleicht beim aufwachen
aber gar nicht so schlecht ist und ich
bin sehr stolz auf euch dass ihr bis
hierhin dieses video geschaut habe und
jetzt gebt ihr dem noch einen daumen
nach oben und kommentiert was nettes und
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
und jetzt tue ich etwas was ich schon
die ganze zeit machen wollte
ich habe den balkon noch nicht gemacht